what is the biggest technological
innovation of your lifetime I mean the
two that I'm the most excited about are
AI is is obviously just a having a huge
moment right now there have been awesome
breakthroughs in the last year on this
and I I just think that this is going to
transform all of the different products
that that we have and everything across
the industry there isn't going to be one
kind of big Central super intelligence I
think that there going to be a lot of
different AIS that people interact with
for different things and that we
interact with throughout our day um and
I'm really excited to to try to help
make that happen the other one that I
think is going to be very exciting over
time um is the is the metaverse right
the ability for people to to basically
feel physically present with another
person um no matter where you actually
are in the
world